August 1962 an American u-2 spy plane
flying over communist Cuba takes a
deeply disturbing photograph
imagine you're taking pictures over
hostile country if you saw this alarm
bells would be ringing immediately the
aerial image starts a chain of events
that takes the United States to the
brink of apocalypse the picture was
taken over la Coloma 100 miles from the
Cuban capital Havana it stands out you
can look at this photo and you can see
they're carving this out of very dense
vegetation this seemingly innocuous
image starts a chain reaction that would
bring the u.s. to the brink of war if
you saw these sights on a photograph and
you put them to anybody in the Pentagon
alarm bells will be ringing immediately
the pattern in the image is recognized
as a footprint for a Soviet
anti-aircraft missile system called
an sa-2
if you look at places where the Soviets
help set up sa-2 sites around the world
Cuba Vietnam later in other places they
all have the same looking footprint when
viewed from above looks like a star
David carved into the ground it
it's an unusual pattern but not once you
understand how these sites are
constructed then it starts to make sense
analysts believe the site in the image
was still under construction at the time
the photo was taken
imagery captured three months later by
US spy planes shows a fully operational
missile base the presence of the sa-2
anti-aircraft missiles tips off US
intelligence that the Soviets must be
trying to protect something important
further reconnaissance flights over the
surrounding area soon discover the
Soviet nuclear missiles the US
government could not tolerate deadly
weapons so close to home right next door
in Cuba right across the water the
Russians of the Soviets had a foothold
there was in the mazing ly frightening
prospect
these sites would trigger 13-day crisis
that brought two of the world's biggest
superpowers to the brink of nuclear war
the Strategic Air Command feed 52
bombers
now flying 24-hour mission after intense
negotiations the Russians backed down
and removed their nukes but short-range
tactical missiles remain to protect
Cuban airspace today modern aerial
imagery of the same site shows no trace
of the weaponry that triggered the
crisis the evidence of humanity's brush
with annihilation is gone but not
forgotten